[Music]
i've got an interesting news story for
you according to a new report that just
came out get ready for this marijuana is
the most popular drug on
earth it's the most popular drug on
earth
so better luck next year bath salts that
make you eat someone else's face
because you know
you know that's climbing the charts
their marketing people have been working
hard working hard on it
this is crazy a man has filed a lawsuit
against kim kardashian and kanye west
claiming they have ties to al qaeda
yeah yeah when al qaeda heard this they
said please do not lump us in with those
maniacs
[Applause]
new jersey uh governor chris christie's
in the news he's under fire he's in
trouble for calling a politician he
doesn't like an sob
yeah meanwhile christy calls a
politician he does like a blt
it's a large fellow
he's a large fellow
a company
i do i really do like these people uh
companies come out with a wedding ring
guaranteed to keep the man from cheating
yeah mostly because the ring doesn't go
on the man's finger
the uh
i'm sorry i
i don't get it
oh you're going to get it
what does that even mean